hi erin how are you doing
i'm doing great thanks
i've been asked to start building a new
inventory tracking system on cloud run
we use cloudround which is serverless to
reduce the ops work needed
the application will use java and spring
boot but i'm not sure how to get that
started on cloud run
no worries martin it's actually pretty
simple these days let me show you
[Music]
so remind me again what kind of app are
we building here it's a pretty standard
web app with an html user interface and
it will connect to a database
all right well first things first how
about we get a simple service created
and deployed
sounds like a good start to me
we'll start by making a new google cloud
platform project for your app
all right and we can call it inventory
tracking app
perfect
once that's created we can open up the
cloud shell
do we need to use the cloud shell for
this though
no that's entirely optional as long as
you have the gcloud command line tool
installed you'll be able to do
everything from your local machine if
you prefer to do that
excellent
well i will use the cloud shell to get
started for convenience
i'm used to using the wizard at
start.spring.io to get new spring boot
applications
that should work great all we'll need is
the web dependency it may be easier to
use the command line version of that to
get the zip file in your cloud shell
environment i sent you the command did
you get it
yep i see it
all right let me run it
looks like i got a zip file with a
starter project uh like i'm used to from
start.spring.io
i'll just unzip it here and open the
editor
okay
all set uh what's next aaron
well that command gave us a good
starting point but we'll need something
to give us a sign of life once we're
running this
let's add a hello world endpoint to help
us with that
uh sure i'll just add a low controller
here
it will return a placeholder inventory
account of a placeholder product for now
and this is just so we can see that all
parts of the system are working
now to get started how can we get this
running from the command line
we can actually run it the same way you
would on your machine then we can hit
the preview button in the top right of
the cloud shell to see it in your
browser
ah there it is very nice so the
application is running from my command
line i can use this for testing as i
build it out
now how can we get this deployed to
cloud run up in the cloud so others can
test the application in the simplest
case we can do it in one line with
gcloud run deploy
wow that is a short top command
but is there a way i can see what kind
of magic is happening behind the scenes
here
absolutely you'll be prompted for a few
things during the run deploy command
like providing the source code location
providing the service name
enabling the cloud run api selecting
your region and enabling artifact
registry hmm i see i did that
now i'm being asked if i want to enable
unauthenticated requests to the service
yeah to make it easy to test here we'll
want to allow unauthenticated requests
after all that enabling is done it'll
start the actual deploy process
now a lot is going on behind the scenes
of this command which you don't need to
know but you might find interesting
what's happening during this step is
that cloud build zips and saves your
source in a cloud storage bucket
uses the cloud native computing
foundation build packs in the background
to build your image
creates a registry to store the
resulting container image if not already
present and creates a cloud run service
to host your app if that's not already
present
wow and just like that with one single
command we're live huh
yes we are
well that was pretty simple uh but for
my app to get to production i'm going to
need some tests and i want them to pass
before i deploy
fair enough we can get that going pretty
quick as well
okay so why don't we get started by
adding a simple failing test
the test checks if one plus one equals
three and it will fail of course and
then i will fix it and if all that works
i can add real tests later on
great
once our test is done we'll have to
inform cloud build that we want to treat
running those steps as their own step
and to stop if they fail
how much config are we looking at for
this aaron one file and just a handful
of lines i'll send you the cloud build
yaml
this file tells cloudbuild to run your
tests
install the project's maven dependencies
build the image using gcloud build
submit and the pack flag to select build
packs
and then deploy the resulting image to
cloud build with gcloud run deploy
okay that makes sense now how do we use
it to run the tests before deployment
well since we have a cloud build yaml
file present in our source directory we
can just run gcloud build submit and it
will look for that file by default
great
[Music]
and as expected it failed good
yeah now we can fix it and rest assured
that we won't be pushing broken builds
to prod down the line
very good
next i'd add my code to source control
then i'd like to automatically run the
tests and deploy to my cloud run test
environment whenever code is committed
to the dev branch
those sound like great next steps
let me show you how to do them in the
next video
thank you for showing me aaron and thank
you everyone for watching if you have
questions for me or aaron please add
them in the comments below
also let us know if there are other
topics you'd like to hear about on this
show
bye
[Music]
you